so um I don't know if you remember but
there's a thing called Mosaic and
there's a thing called Netscape
Navigator so you were there in the
beginning uh what about the interface to
the internet how do you think the
browser changes and who gets to own the
browser we've got to see some very
interesting browsers
uh Firefox I mean all the variants of
Microsoft Internet Explorer Edge and uh
now Chrome
um the actual
I mean it seems like a dumb question to
ask but do you think we'll still have
the web browser
so I I have an eight-year-old and he's
super into it's like Minecraft and
learning to code and doing all this
stuff so I I of course I was very proud
I couldn't bring sort of fire down from
the mountain to my kid and I brought him
chat GPT and I hooked him up yeah on his
honest on his on his laptop and I was
like you know this is the thing that's
gonna answer all your questions and he's
like okay
and I'm like but it's gonna answer all
the questions and he's like well of
course like it's a computer of course it
answers all your questions like what
else would a computer be good for Dad
um it's never impressive not impressed
in the least two weeks passed
um and he has some question
um and I say well have you asked chat
jpt and he's like Dad Bing is better oh
and why is Bing better is because it's
built into the browser because he's like
look I have the Microsoft edge browser
and like it's got Bing right here and
then he doesn't know this yet but one of
the things you can do with being an edge
is there's a setting where you can use
it to basically talk to any web page
because it's sitting right there next to
the uh next to the next to the browser
and by the way which includes PDF
documents and so you can in in the way
they've implemented an edge with bang is
you can load a PDF and then you can you
can ask it questions which is the thing
you you can't do currently in inches
chat GPT so they're you know they're
they're gonna they're gonna push the the
metal I think that's great you know
they're going to push the melding and
see if there's a combination thing there
Google's rolling out this thing the
magic button uh which is implemented and
they put in Google Docs right and so you
go into you know Google Docs and you
create a new document and you you know
you instead of like you know starting to
type you just you know say it press the
button and it starts to like generate
content for you right like is that the
way that it'll work
um is it going to be a speech UI where
you're just going to have an earpiece
and talk to it all day long you know is
it going to be a like these are all like
this is exactly the kind of thing that I
don't this is exactly the kind of thing
I don't think is possible to forecast I
think what we need to do is like run all
those experiments um and and so one
outcome is we come out of this with like
a super browser that has AI built in
that's just like amazing the other look
there's a real possibility that the
whole I mean look there's a possibility
here that the whole idea of a screen and
windows and all this stuff just goes
away because like why do you need that
if you just have a thing that's just
telling you whatever you need to know
and also so there's apps that you can
use you don't really use them you know
being a Linux guy and windows guy
uh there's one window of the browser
that with which you can interact with
internet but on the phone you can also
have apps so I can interact with Twitter
through the app or through the web
browser
and um that seems like an obvious
distinction but why have the web browser
in that case if one of the apps starts
becoming the everything app what are
elon's trying to do with Twitter but
there could be others it could be like a
Bing app it could be a Google app that
just doesn't really do search but just
like
do what I guess AOL did back in the day
or something where it's all right there
and it changes
um
it changes the nature of the internet
because
the where the content is hosted who owns
the data who owns the content how what
is what is the kind of content you
create how do you make money by creating
content for the content creators
uh all of that
or you could just keep being the same
which is like with just the nature web
pages changes and the nature of content
but there'll still be a web browser
because uh web browser is a pretty sexy
product it just seems to work because it
like you have an interface a window into
the world and then the world can be
anything you want and as the world will
evolve it could be different programming
languages it can be animated maybe it's
three-dimensional and so on
yeah it's interesting do you think we'll
still have the web browser every every
um every medium becomes the content for
the next one so you know the AI will be
able to give you a browser whenever you
want um oh interesting yeah another way
to think about it is maybe what the
browser is maybe it's just the escape
hatch right and which is maybe kind of
what it is today right which is like
most of what you do is like inside a
social network or inside a search engine
or inside you know somebody's app or
inside some controlled experience right
but then every once in a while there's
something where you actually want to
jailbreak you want to actually get free
the web browser is the fu to the man
you're allowed to that's the free
internet yeah back the way it was in the
90s so here's something I'm proud of so
nobody really talks about here's
something I'm proud of which is the web
the web the browser the web servers
they're all they're still Backward
Compatible all the way back to like 1992
right so like you can put up a you can
still you know what the big breakthrough
the web early on the big breakthrough
was it made it really easy to read but
it also made it really easy to write I
mean it really easy to publish and and
we literally made it so easy to publish
we made it not only so it was easy to
publish content it was actually also
easy to actually write a web server
right and you can literally write a web
server in four lines of real code and
and you could start publishing content
on it and you could set whatever rules
you want for the content whatever
censorship no censorship whatever you
want you could just do that as long as
you had an IP address right you could do
that that still works right like that
still works exactly as I just described
so this is part of my reaction to all of
this like you know all this just
censorship pressure and all this you
know these issues around control and all
this stuff which is like maybe we need
to get back a little bit more to the
wild west like the wild west is still
out there now they will try to chase you
down like they'll try to you know people
who want to censor will try to take away
your your um you know your domain name
and they'll try to take away your
payments account and so forth if they
really don't like what you what you're
saying but but nevertheless you like
unless they literally are intercepting
you with the ISP level like you can
still put up a thing
um and so I I don't know I think that's
important to preserve right like because
because because I mean one is just a
freedom argument but the other is a
creativity argument which is you want to
have the escape hatch so that the kid
with the idea is able to realize the
idea because to your point on page rank
you actually don't know what the next
big idea is right nobody called Larry
Page and told him to develop page rank
like he came up with that on his own and
you want to always I I think leave the
escape hatch for the next you know kid
or the next Stanford grad student to
have the Breakthrough idea and be able
to get it up and running before anybody
notices